uh hello my name is jeremy allen white
from the new movie the rental
i'm here with buzzfeed reading thirst
tweets
[Music]
jeremy allen white is honestly one of
the most gorgeous
people alive holy crap that's really
really nice i really want to start
a new blog just for jeremy allen but
i mean have you seen that thing damn
that's funny i
i feel like i i have such a non-existent
um
but my wife always makes fun of my butt
lip gallagher is awkwardly
sexy like hey hottie i agree bro
can we all just have a moment of silence
to appreciate lip gallagher's
sexy smirk sure
i would bottom for lip gallagher all
right really want lip gallagher to choke
me
to death with his beautiful muscly arms
that's truly how i want to go out no
i don't think it is lip gallagher spit
in my mouth
i'm severely spooked buzzfeed i jump on
the chance to [ __ ]
jeremy allen white and cameron monahan
shouts to cam threesome at different
times
either or i don't care i want to send
that to cameron
lip gallagher is still a daddy that's
that's simple
i dreamt i made out with jeremy allen
white and let me tell you
real life ain't worth living i want to
live in that world
yes ma'am very very very nice
i want lip gallagher not the actor but
the fictional character okay
to punch me in the face so that i can
thank him
and suck his okay bye wow i
would say lip gallagher wouldn't be into
it
nor i i really wish jeremy allen white
had a twitter so i could tell him about
every
elaborate fantasy i've had that involved
him
i am in love i'm sorry i don't have
twitter but that's nice jeremy allen
white can be the father of my kids
sorry but it was all exclamation points
and i had about three different sex
streams
all with jeremy allen white which is odd
because shameless wasn't even
on last night and just got in there i
had a dream last night that jeremy allen
white held my hand
and kissed me and we cuddled and it was
literally
the best dream i've ever had that's
really sweet and very uh
very very tame i don't have twitter so
yeah a lot of that is brand uh
brand spanking new ideas i think it's
the reason i will continue not to have
twitter yeah
you